nerd wars Vin Diesel vs. Marvel
characters take two so this week we're
doing a Vin Diesel from Riddick
yes or Riddick or as Vin Diesel or
ridiculous that movie versus versus The
Punisher The Punisher be one of the
baddest characters blackest wearing
character with the skull on his chest
and all the Marvel Universe
yeah I'd say I'd say you're right yeah
you got that one I got that one point
Riddick
but no how is that all right I know jive
I name a fact I get a point which as
people watch you know I don't do that
very often Jeff why don't you go ahead
kick off the argument okay I am gonna
give Riddick the battle if only for his
extra human vision he polished his
eyeballs polished his eyes I haven't
seen the Punisher do anything remotely
that badass Riddick he lives in this
world where it's like you know he's in
outer space they have space cards
something night vision
that's his friggin power night vision I
got news punisher has night vision guy
you've been trapped in interstellar
minds here's how a battle between
Punisher and and freakin Riddick would
work in a mine I win I win
no Betty say that isn't punishes like
weird my glasses Adam can't even see
right now put him on go ahead you know
you're a friggin idiot Jeff you're
friggin idiot all right
like seriously critics only thing is
being able to see that was that's it's
pretty much like a race of warrior you
know here's came from a warrior race
yeah and he's the last surviving guy and
he was an elite warrior in the warrior
race let me let me ask you something
mm-hmm have you ever read Punisher vs.
the Marvel Universe have you ever read
freakin Riddick fanfic Punisher kills
the Marvel Universe Punisher kills
everyone in the Marvel Universe Captain
America including Captain America with a
gun with a gun what point xxx xxx just
won that battle
xxx isn't the Punisher there's a
difference there's no there's a
difference let's get caring there's a
difference keep arguing this [ __ ]
alright all I go to ultimate trump card
ballot you make you have ultimate trump
card one more point no forget about one
more
one more point yeah one more point is I
just want to mention some of the other
crappy movies Vin Diesel's been in the
pacifier all right you're telling me the
guy from the pacifier can beat the
Punisher absolutely wrong Iron Giant -
Iron Giant
another turd what yes you're dead
you heard it dead to me you heard it
here it's the ultimate point yeah let's
hear it
freakin ridic spent an entire movie with
Claudia Black Point Riddick no that's
not the back boy hottest women and all
sci-fi in my name in my book fire escape
on the best science that has to do joint
Riddick that has nothing to do with a
fight between these two people that has
nothing to do with the fight but okay
these do people that mine he wins the
mine scenario hands-down he wins the
club that he wins the woman's scenario
hands down what what is uh what does he
got going for him what Riddick nothing
Punisher the only way that Riddick would
beat the Punisher is if affirmative
action got involved because since he's
mentally [ __ ] they probably just
give it to him Riddick basically took
out an entire empire it took out an
entire empire I've already mentioned
Punisher took out every superhero that
exists in the entire Marvel Universe
yeah and Riddick took out an entire
empire yeah an entire empire of [ __ ]
yeah you heard me did you see those guys
yeah the kill Maury or whatever the
Frick don't [ __ ] warp through space
kind of yeah they can barely describe it
an intergalactic species of emo kids
okay that's what that's what Riddick can
do that's yeah way to go way to go next
time there's a rave I need to break up
I'll call a Vin Diesel but if I need a
badass guy to get killed I'm called when
the Punisher and next time I have a
party I'm calling Vin Diesel - I'm not
inviting the people you sure cuz he
can't get any ladies he'd be fun at a
party he would be if this was an
argument who would be a better party
guest I'd say Vin Diesel Vin Diesel in a
heartbeat
keep posting your suggestions I'll keep
arguing and making Adam upset
you